for the marlins we know and we love them
sandy alcatra a fourth start of the
season coming off a win against the rays
when six innings one run eight
strikeouts has pitched well against the
phillies
hoskins hitting 258 with nine home runs
tapped up the third base line that's a
fair ball and it is going to roll
right past the third base bag
now that is a thing of beauty
you could hear how far yell and let it
go let it go let it go
i think the thought was once it hit that
field turf
that it would kick foul
and that puts runners on second and
third with one out jt ramuto coming up
the former marlin
to two rolled left side that'll get a
run home
as they throw out jt jt with his 28th
rbi of the season the phillies take a
one-nothing lead and there's jake
garrieta there he had a 3-4 with a 5.67
earned run average coming off a good
start and hopefully he can duplicate
that here tonight lead off walk to
dickerson
to starling martay
that one is fair inside the third base
line dickerson is on his way to third
going to be extra bases for marte and
they're going to wave around dickerson
here he comes there will be no throw on
the rbi double from starling martay
now alex balm with a man at first base
matala gets it sharply just over the
glove of chisholm into right center
field and it goes right past marte knapp
is going to third and he's being
wave told
also the third base is balm the phillies
score a run it's now a 2-1 ball game not
only did marte miss it but he just
stopped it didn't go after it
easily no home runs three runs batted in
and a line drive base hit it to left
center field that'll score alec boom the
phillies take a 3-1 lead 96-97 this is a
change up not only does he stay back on
it stays through it and drives it the
other way what a piece of hitting there
by hazley dickerson the runner at third
he started the ending with the base hit
starling marte a bloop single into right
joyce's last five games entering tonight
hitting over 350. now three and two
and joyce in the air to deep center
field hazely going back onto the track
makes the catch and both runners are
going to tag here again it will be a
sacrifice fly for matt joyce three to
two here in the third inning another jam
here for alcatra first and third nobody
out so now it's andrew knapp
is the strikeout of nap right there
nobody advances in the big out number
one baum who's singled off of alcatra
here's the pitch boom swings and lines
one towards left center field that's a
base hit and it'll be cut in the alley
by dickerson gregorius will score around
to third goes segura and alex baume with
a base hit has extended the philly's
lead it's now four to two hisley singled
homer on his first time up he squares to
bunt and the bunt is dropped down here
comes segura he'll score the throw to
first is in time and a squeeze play as
adam hazley drives home another run for
the fills they lead it five to two and
you talk about perfect timing first and
third situation one out
and you just put a run on the board get
another one how do you do it tack it on
right there with a safety squeeze
and back come the marlins second and
third one down another number nine man
alfaro against his former team
rolled to second for segura that'll get
one run in as cooper scores to make it
five to three another day another rbi
for jorge alfaro top of the fifth inning
it's five to three so now jt romuto
that one's hit well out to left field
going back on it is dickerson and it is
gone
a home run for jt
that's his 11th of the year the phillies
lead it now 6-3
i'd say he kept his shoulder in on that
one tom you sure did that's what you do
with an o2 mistake he knew it right
after contact already on his way to the
hill and he'll take the baseball from
arietta so that will end his night he
will finish shy of six innings only five
and two thirds tonight he threw 106
pitches here's jojo romero this will be
his seventh game jazz at third
alfaro at first and another big spot
here for the marlins tying run at the
plate
swinging a foul tip hung onto by jt and
the side is retired
workman's 17th game overall nine of 10
and save opportunities between boston
and philly and the marlins will have
them bloated for starling martay the 1-0
pitch
is in the air right field it sends
harper back near the wall and it's off
the wall
harper chases it down two runs are in
here comes the third and starling
martinez tied the game with two outs in
the eighth inning
the dugout is going wild
finally breaking through tonight with a
big base hit with runners in scoring
position
it sets up a chance for the marlins to
get a walk-off win brian anderson first
one at the bottom of the ninth is hit
sharply past didi gregorius a base hit
and that is how the ninth inning starts
with a knock from brian anderson and
it's gonna be monte harrison to take
over as the pinch runner that's your
winning run if coop can find a gap
somewhere harrison can get to top speed
rather quickly harrison goes
a chopper to third
[Applause]
and they make the play over at first and
harrison into scoring position rojas
with a double in the fourth one out of
four harrison going for third throw from
rail muto is not in time harrison's safe
oh
the bravery well i wasn't sure we would
see it
but i'll tell you what monte took a big
risk big reward well they will
intentionally walk miguel rojas and jazz
chisholm i think he should go he's going
right now on the ball that's bounced in
and blocked by real muto
so that erases the double play
2-2
swing and a miss
that'll bring up alfaro marlins so good
with two outs
alfaro ground ball
in comes mate
it's a marlins win
look at how far it was he's mobbed by
his teammates